hi there I'm Hannah Prosser Robinson for
gamespot here on the floor in the
Nintendo booth at e3 2014 I'm standing
here with my new friend Christina
Christina what do you do for Nintendo I
actually work with developers so that's
what I do on a normal basis and then I
get to come to e3 fantastic are you
enjoying it so far yes been a long week
but it's awesome and this far that it
looks great Jose just started in your
booth is just stuffed with people very
oh it's so exciting we actually had
people in the booth before the actual
official open so that is it is very
exciting I talked to a lot of people who
were either just coming in or at the
front of the line that said Nintendo was
their first off they were so excited
about the games being in here that and
especially they talked a lot about super
smash brothers for the wii u coming out
has that been a lot of excitement for
you guys in a huge excitement and so we
have it's a huge presence here at the
booth we've got this big screen back
here where people can actually play and
then watch each other so it's a
competition and then we also over at the
nokia theatre have an invitational today
so people actually get to compete and
the theaters would be full of people
watching so yeah smash is huge shred
there's lots and lots of stations where
people are already lined up to play what
do you think the chances are if somebody
was coming into e3 today you know how
long do you think they'd have to wait to
play super smash brothers let's see
looking at this line it's probably at
least a half hour maybe more to play and
we just started so you better get here
quick if you're going to do it so
there's a lot of nostalgia wrapped up in
a lot of Nintendo games especially super
smash brothers have you heard a lot from
people that they're really hoping for
certain things that they loved about
other smash brothers games I think the
main thing is just the characters people
are really excited about the characters
and you know new characters like me
personally Megaman when I saw that mega
man was going to be one of the
characters I was very excited so I mean
it's just smash is one of the best it's
one of my favorite franchises anyways so
so you know another aspect of super
smash brothers is that it's in the past
like you said been very competitive
people are looking to compete against
each other in turn
and things do you think that this
version of Smash Brothers has the
potential to be as competitive as say
like smash brothers melee or those ones
that have even gone professional gamer I
think so definitely and I think also
adding the me aspect to it will really
get people excited and really get people
involved because they'll actually be
able to kind of battle each other so can
you tell me a little bit about how that
works if people haven't heard about that
um basically I mean you just get to use
your me and you get to choose what type
of fighter your me is gonna be and then
choose the different actual like
fighting styles so very cool so so if
you were to make your me what fighting
styles would you use hmm I like the one
with the sword it does look pretty epic
to have a sort yeah I think that would
be it so I always played a lot of curvy
so it was like the range and the
grabbing and spitting and all that I
don't know if I could do that with a me
do you think I could I think there's
some of the weapon options where you can
actually like throw things and that kind
of stuff sweet I love throwing things
awesome alright so you said your
favorite characters Megaman have you had
a chance to play much smash brothers and
if so what was like your favorite part I
have played a lot of it um like I said I
mean my actual favorite character to
play is zero suit samus um I liked
megaman was a lot of fun but it's just
really intuitive it's really easy to get
into and it's it's a blast so if someone
is a little bit less competitive they
can still jump in and play with their
friends and have a good time yes
definitely definitely I know I'm really
looking forward to playing it thank you
so much for taking time out of what
looks like a really busy schedule to
talk to us but if you tell me what
you're most excited let's start that
phrase over shall we I can you tell I'm
really excited tell me what you are most
excited for in Smash Brothers by
tweeting at Anna processor with the
hashtag hashtag gamespot III